Hm, ha, ha,
oh my
, I was touched by the reunion after a long time, but it seems like you're still practicing
.
I wonder if there will be high school students if it's for this reason that I'll have to think about management.
It's a team competition, but
[music]
Well, the competition is only on Amazon now. It's
a competition I made
.
Oops, there are circumstances that only the role can understand.I wonder if it's a bonus for those who get along so well that they get into fights
I'm talented, I won't let you smoke all the cherry blossoms I'm your
mother
[music] For
now, today's frog is like this.
In the
junior division, children from all over the country gather together to learn the basics of the hut, which has a barra, and Donna.
Tonamo Souichi
[Music]